españa es el país europeo más afectado
por las llamas en lo que va de 2022
según datos del sistema europeo de
información sobre incendios forestales
la superficie quemada este año alcanza
las 190 mil hectáreas cuando hace unos
días ésta no llegaba a las 90.000 y
supera en siete meses y medio el récord
de hectáreas calcinadas de todo el 2012
el peor año en la historia del país
ahora mismo hay más de una decena de
incendios activos nueve de ellos graves
y varios centenares de personas siguen
desalojadas la leve bajada de
temperaturas en el país sobre todo
durante las noches a partir del martes
ayudó a que las llamas pudieran ser
controladas en el incendio de zamora al
oeste de españa frontera con portugal
que ha sido el que más hectáreas ha
arrasado hasta el momento y el que se
cobró las primeras dos víctimas mortales
de esta temporada sin embargo sigue
haciendo muchísimo calor en gran parte
del país y el riesgo de incendios sigue
siendo extremo varias de las regiones
afectadas están considerando pedirle al
gobierno central que las declaren como
zonas catastróficas mientras que el
presidente del gobierno pedro sánchez
volvió a insistir hoy en la necesidad de
que las políticas ambientales sean de
estado y no varían según quienes en el
ejecutivo de un año para otro mañana
jueves el gobierno y los sindicatos se
reunirán para definir la elaboración de
un estatuto básico de bomberos
forestales piden mejorar las condiciones
de trabajo piden también más recursos y
menos precariedad además de un mejor
cuidado del campo a lo largo del año no
sólo en verano para evitar que estos
incendios sean tan voraces